hello everyone Karen Warren with film
courage the radio show we've just had a
power-packed hour with mr. Matthew
freighter here in studio how are you and
we touched on some interesting things in
his interview and one of which was on
the topic of being bullied as a kid and
I know I had the same thing happened so
it it kind of affects you later on in
life and we decided to kind of take it
in another direction and that some it in
the term of social bullying as an adult
because it happens it's on a different
level and I think it's important to talk
about especially in this industry it is
a cutthroat industry and bullying can
occur in sometimes slight ways but ways
that still cut and Malcolm curious your
take on that social bullying in this
industry well this industry so highly
competitive that you know just have to
it's really it's really important to
sort of know who you are and I think for
me personally out here 21 years old I
didn't know who I was I was as green be
living you know just getting to LA and
you know I don't have the car and the
money and all these material things that
you know we're all prone to in our adult
life to desire to have to give us
definition or whatever so I went through
it you know from 21 on even said even to
this day to walk into an audition and
you know you're up against so many
different people are so much competition
I think people refer to it out here is
it's so competitive and they don't want
to say like you better you know you
better watch out because people will
step on you and do what
can to to get that edge you know above
you to get the role or whatever social
bullying out here is is extremely you
know prevalent in this business and I
think you know learning to be
comfortable with who you are and what
you have to offer is very important and
I think if you know if it takes any
amount of time to figure that out about
yourself You Know Who am I am I the type
of person who enjoys being around people
in my the type of person who can get
along with anybody and I the type of
person who can get back in any way shape
or form those sort of definitions for
yourself I think can really help you in
in those situations where other people
are trying to step on you or take away
your positive energy or make you feel
less than perfect it sounds cheesy to
say like an after school special but
everybody is perfect in their own way
whatever you bring to the table I feel
like as long as you're being honest or
being true to who you are I'm going to
find something about you that I can
appreciate that I can really like about
you and I think that's important to have
in this town especially with so much
competition and I'm curious too when you
find yourself in an instance where you
sense you're being bull
maybe at an audition or what have you
how do you deflect it without being too
combative but come like you know what
they say your best defense is a good
offense yeah oh man that's a great
question for me personally um I used to
take things very personally really
really personally and sort of getting
into this business through doing a
little bit of modeling a high fashion
stuff you're so focused on how you look
it's very material so it's very sort of
external ice to take if an agent when I
first moved out here and i met with you
know 50 agents every agent had some
other way of putting me down which we've
all been through you know you're too
tall or you know your nose is too big or
whatever whatever it might be I just
have learned to laugh at all that's up
now so if I get into a situation last
week I'm at an audition and there you
know I you know you go to sign in on the
other audition sheet you see all these
actors from all these big agencies
you're like oh my gosh there's from CA
and paradigm and all these big and I I'm
nobody knows my agent I don't care I at
least that have an agent right but what
I do is I just I bring funny and humor
into it in any way that I can if I
experience someone bullying somebody
else or someone tries to bring the
energy to me it's a little bit of
sarcasm goes a long way you know for
instance I can give a really point of
example at this particular audition I
signed in put my agent down and then the
guy who signed it after me we looked
very much the same so you know obviously
we're up against each other he put down
his agent he goes oh soo so you're up by
this agency to kind of set out loud so
everyone can hear it in their own you
know
and is like I do exactly what was
happening I said I said yeah he was also
how are they doing for you I said
actually fantastic i just did this movie
and i got to something coming I said who
are you with and and he was kind of
taken aback that I was just so forward
about it he said oh one with phenyl
songs over at this big agency I said
yeah how's that working for it and I
just put him on the spot in front of you
know and that's but I just feel like
like you should deflecting I just don't
I don't take it on anymore I just kind
of like a tennis game you know if you're
going to hit a hard ball at me I'm gonna
I'm just gonna put my racquet okay I
don't need to hit it hard at you I'm
just gonna put my rag out there let the
ball come back to you I don't know
something like that you know just use
humor and I think I think the best like
you said the best defense is a good
offense I think the best defense is to
be able to make fun of yourself a little
bit especially in this town when
everyone takes themselves so seriously
don't take yourself so seriously you
know yeah and then lastly I think you
mentioned to about giving back and
that's something that's been more of a
calling for you and in sort of a
spiritual thing that you're interested
in giving back and charity work is that
right yeah absolutely it's something
I've always been interested in it comes
from my grandmother my grandma Bev and
my mother back in Michigan's my mom and
her mother they volunteer and do things
all the time out of the goodness of
their heart and after I hit the age of
30 which was a year and a half ago I
just by myself around children I love
children like my daddy clock started to
take a little bit louder EEE now so I've
started to dedicate a lot of my free
time to raising money for special needs
children
and things like that I co-produce an
event back the end of June there's a
wonderful event for these two charitable
organizations that deal with special
needs children we have another event
coming up november seventh that's going
to be down here in LA it's near marina
del rey and for me personally the giving
back with charity I can't even I can't
even describe like what it does for the
soul it feels so good to know like where
first of all where I started where I am
now how all the people that have helped
me out we're on the way whether it be
your family your friends you know new
friends that you're making along the way
but to be able to give back any of your
time in any of your positive energy to
to something for children that did don't
necessarily have what I was given as a
kid you know I never I never really
dealt with any social sort of you know
disabilities for physical disabilities
or anything like that there's a lot of
people in the world that that are living
their lives this way and need to be
recognized that these are where all
people were all filled with love and joy
in some way and to see the look on these
kids faces who have special needs from
autism on down the line for me
personally that just it does more for me
than booking a role in a movie or you
know getting you know what my buddy and
I called a meeting factor everyone's
about me me me BB i really encourage
anyone who's watching this or tuning the
show to give back in some way shape or
form and ironically the more you give of
yourself the more comes back to you so i
just kind of that's like I don't know a
universal law of attraction in some way
shape or form whatever you put out
you're going to get back so for me it's
it's it's just something I want to do my
entire life is to be charitable in some
way shape or form not just for kids but
kids is a big part of it children and I
continue to continue to do that for the
rest of my life and hopefully as my
career growth and more people take
notice of who I am if my name
spotlight I want to help guide that
spotlight to people who may not have you
know as good a fortune or or have been
given the opportunities i think it was
long-winded but that's my share
Oh